in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Andrew
and Katarina are here
hey how are you hey Dave we're good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
Atlanta Georgia and drove all the way to
Nashville to do a debt-free scream yes
sir well it's good to have y'all welcome
welcome thank you so how much debt have
you paid off we've paid off eighteen
thousand three hundred and ninety four
dollars and forty three cents I love it
and how long did that take you
we had the plan started at ten months
but due to job and consistency we didn't
start paying off until seven months so a
total of seven months seven months
that's a quick very well done and your
household income during that time was
what we were making before he had a job
24:28 thousand dollars and once he got a
job it was 54,000 gotcha and then do two
raises now we're at 80,000 oh wow
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
I'm a marketing manager very cool and
I'm a chemist so what happened 10/7
months ago that caused you guys to
decide to get out of debt we got married
oh that will do it graduated college and
we got married okay so both of you got
came out of college started or got
married and started your lives off yep
okay so you sit down now it's grown-up
time we've got to do this what kind of
debt was the eighteen thousand school
loans car and a credit card okay I'm
married into it married into Danny oh oh
that may not last if you keep that up
okay so alright so Katherine I had some
debt and and and we sit down at the
coming back from the honeymoon we sit
down and we look at this situation
tell me how this conversation went what
we were talking about well it actually
started before the honeymoon I got a
graduation gift Total Money Makeover and
my mom had halfway funded my $1,000
emergency fund and I read the book on
our honeymoon and I got a little -
gizelle in tents too early and kind of
overwhelmed her and so the first
conversation didn't go that well in fact
it didn't go at all she keep discussing
this on your
honeymoon is probably it was your timing
pretty much so I was very fortunate to
have her she knew a lot about you and
she's very very good with money I said I
was she was more than capable of
creating a budget without me driving the
point home over and over again
okay Caterina I want to hear your side
of this this is great my mother had told
me about Dave Ramsey for years so I knew
all the points but he kept telling me
all you have to read the book you have
to do it with me and I'm like well just
let's just make a budget I know all the
points and so but for the first three
months he just brought it up every
single day about every other
conversation I was excited did you ever
did you ever read the book I did
whatever we did the class okay oh you
took the financial base class yeah okay
my boss would end up sending us to the
class in January so I know Steve Alaska
is listening and he sent us a big
shout-out well that's a good employer
very good okay so we get past all the
finger-pointing and all that stuff and
now we sit down start working together
and seven months later boom just like
that it's gone really really fast plus
you got great jobs you increase your
income everything's going great sounds
like you're just a zum-zum everything's
going a whole lot better it's yeah yeah
a little bit of a rocky start on a plan
though okay yeah you probably should
very good you guys okay so advice to
couples who are thinking of getting
married they're engaged and one or the
other has some data both have some debt
what do you that say the keys were for
you all to be able to get out of debt
this fast because you did it really fast
it was definitely working together I
mean and you know actually sitting down
together and and getting on the same
page with everything okay yeah you have
to communicate you have to be willing to
put some things aside and then move
other things up higher on the list and
you know we work together and it was it
was a great experience what was the
hardest thing that you had to sacrifice
that you had to say we're not doing this
so we can hit this goal say for me it
was
the fact that we were starting a home
and building a house and and you know
starting our lives and we didn't have
the all of our other couple friends are
like buying new things and I want things
that match and mm-hmm he would barely
eat a five-dollar sandwich so you know I
couldn't do it that was my biggest thing
is I wouldn't eat lunch I would rather
not spend money on a lunch and just put
it aside so mmm you know but that's
words that later but that people do I
mean they get married I've got my kids
or your all's age and I've watched their
friends they get married and they go
fill a house full of furniture on that
and it's all matching from rooms there
they went and you know all that right
everything's a little perfect little
world and so a Pinterest world we live
in you know yeah it's it is keeping up
with the Joneses a little bit there's
that peer pressure to go now I'm still
sitting on the beanbag from college you
know yeah this thing's 400 years old
this chair look at this thing yeah and
it's not even a nice antique it's just
old you know and that kind of thing and
yet you and yet you've pulled off
something here to wear with it
$80,000 income and no payments at all
and you know how to work together and
you know how to control your money
you'll be able to buy anything you want
it feels so good it feels good very cool
well congratulations very proud of you
you're heroes I appreciate you coming on
here and being real because it is it is
always a struggle sometimes people act
like they're too cool for schooling you
guys are just fun I'm very well done
very well done all right Andrew and
Katarina from Atlanta Georgia
$18,000 paid off in seven months making
twenty eight and fifty four then eighty
as they get into their jobs count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
that's fun absolutely fun very well done
oh good stuff good stuff hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind